[Musique]
il faut savoir s'agripper puis se
dépêcher si vous tapez un mur de 15
mètres en 6 secondes et vous manquerez
encore cinq ans deux centièmes pour
égaler leur record du monde mais vos
efforts pourrait valoir de l'or puisque
en 2020 à tokyo l'escaladent couronnera
son premier champion olympique un
certain poids était même obligé de
regarder les prises ce que je suis allé
parce que tu as fait tellement fois
accès zakeri mathieu s'accroche à
l'espoir de participer au jeu pratiqué
l'escaladé la même dans sa zone de
confort
sincèrement si comme sport en temple on
réessaie autre un peu plus loin pour ton
encore plus simple belle progression
cinquième année au gem stable à
l'escaladé ditto n'était que se
distingue par son nouveau format de
compétition trois épreuves le même jour
le bloc est un test où l'athlète dispose
de cinq minutes pour résoudre un
problème se frayer un chemin sur le mur
l'épreuve de difficultés force le
participant à atteindre la cible la plus
élevée sans faire de schutter et à
l'épreuve de vitesse
le grimpeur se transforme sprinteurs
dans les routes 1 l'espoir est très
jeune alors il ya des choses qui sont
carrément à inventer
entendez d'étudiants à prendre sur le
format sur le commun sont la sélection
une différence au niveau des athlètes
sont beaucoup plus sérieux dans leur
processus simon pelé se garder
l'alimentation la préparation
psychologique change mais qu'on avait
déjà établi comme le grand favori pour
décrocher le premier titre olympique
un canadien quatre fois champion du
monde du combiné dont la renommée n'est
plus à faire mais quand ébloui souvent
la galerie lors d'émissions télé
chan
son enfant on a tellement été
travaillées a tellement été raffiné que
y est devenue une brute des scarlets qui
avance à moi parce qu'elle lui ait
vraiment pas grand comme moi qui
compense vraiment faisant des mouvements
dynamiques hugo rêve déjà d'être le
prochain chambre mais quand ce garçon
n'a que 13 ans et participe déjà à ses
premiers championnats panaméricains
un défi de taille l'attendait au sto m
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
c'est ma grande
je trouvais à place des prend les deux
mains comme se plaît à mélanger
parce je monte mon pied pour pouvoir
aller chercher chaque vache est passé à
son deuxième essai hugo a été en mesure
de toucher à la plaque
une petite victoire pour un petit
bonhomme dont le parcours vers le monde
de l' escalade aurait pu connaître une
fin abrupte
il ya un peu par tout un tas d'outils de
lire un peu partout dans les armées
allemandes et une branche le cd puis il
ya une fracture du crâne d'une balle
fracture du crâne y avait sept ans puis
depuis ce temps là il fait la spéciale
de façon sécuritaire contrôler des fois
l'escaladent un nouveau sport olympique
le public n'a qu'à bien se tenir jean
françois poirier radio canada